Veamos si podemos calcular el resultado de dividir
2 ÷ 0.1 o una décima. Pausa el video e intenta
resolverlo. Muy bien, vamos a hacerlo juntos.
Hay un par de formas en las que podemos hacer
esto. Una forma es pensar todo en términos
de décimas, ¿a cuántas décimas equivalen 2
enteros? Un entero es igual a 10 décimas, entonces
2 enteros equivalen a 20 décimas. Entonces puedo
reescribir el 2 como 20 décimas, por lo tanto,
queda: 20 décimas entre, y en lugar de escribirlo
de esta forma -0.1, puedo escribir 1 décima, que es
lo mismo, entre una décima. Entonces, si tengo 20
de algo y lo divido entre grupos de 1 de ese algo,
¿cuántos grupos voy a tener? Bien, voy a tener 20
grupos iguales de 1. Entonces: 20 décimas ÷ 1 décima = 20. Otraforma de hacer esto es escribir el 0.1, la décima,
como una fracción: podemos escribirlo como 2
entre, y lo voy a escribir como una fracción,
entre un 1/10, 1 sobre 10, y, bueno, ya sabemos
que dividir entre un décimo es lo mismo que
multiplicar por 10, así que esto será igual a
2 x 10, y esto nos lleva al mismo resultado que
obtuvimos antes. ¿Cuánto es 2 x 10? Pues esto,
será igual a 20. Qué bueno que obtuvimos el
mismo resultado, de otro modo no serían métodos
equivalentes. Hagamos otro ejemplo. Digamos que
queremos saber cuánto es 6 ÷ 1/10. Pausa el
video e intenta resolverlo. Bueno, podemos
hacer lo mismo: ¿cuántas décimas son 6 enteros?
Son 60 décimas, así que voy a reescribir esto
como 60 décimas ÷ 1 décima, ¿y a cuánto es igual
esto? Bueno, si tengo 60 de algo y lo divido en
grupos de 1 de ese algo, tendré, entonces, 60
grupos iguales de 1, así que esto será igual a
60. Probablemente puedes ver un patrón: cuando
dividimos entre 1/10 realmente multiplicamos por
10, cuando dividimos entre 1/10 realmente
multiplicamos por 10. Y podríamos hacer lo
mismo que vimos aquí arriba, podemos decir que 6
÷ 0.1 décima es lo mismo que 6 ÷ 1/10 escrita como
fracción, lo que será igual a 6 x 10; o también
podrías decir: 6 x 10 / 1 -cualquiera de las dos
formas-, 6 x 10 / 1, que es lo mismo que 10, y esto
una vez más será igual a 60. Creo que ya vieron el
patrón general: dividir entre 1/10 es lo mismo
que multiplicar por 10. Ahora, ¿qué pasa si con
lo que estamos tratando son centésimas? Digamos
que queremos resolver cuánto es 7 ÷ 0.01, ¿cuánto
será? Pausa el video e inténtalo. Muy bien,
podemos hacer el mismo ejercicio: 1 entero
es igual a 100 centésimas, entonces 7 enteros
equivalen a 700 centésimas, lo voy a escribir así:
esto es igual a 700 centésimas entre 1 centésima.
Si tengo 700 de algo y lo divido en grupos iguales
de 1 de ese algo voy a tener 700 grupos iguales,
así que esto será igual a 700. Entonces, dividir
entre 1 centésima será lo mismo que multiplicar
por 100. También podríamos reescribir esto como
una fracción para comprobar que los principios que
vimos antes también se aplican aquí. Escribamos
esto como 7 ÷ 1 / 100, entre 1 centésimo,
y esto será lo mismo que 7 x 100 / 1,
o 7 x 100 -siete por cien- que, una vez más, nos dará 700.
Creoque el patrón es claro: dividir entre una décima es lo mismo que multiplicar por 10, dividir entre
una centésima es lo mismo que multiplicar por 100.